Thank you for coming in today.
We appreciate you're taking the time to interview with us for a position with our firm...
...and I hope it's a good experience for both of us.
Let me just take a few seconds and explain how this will flow.
My job, if you will, is to learn as much about you as I can...
...and in a fairly short period of time.
That will mean that you'll have to do most of the talking...
...and hopefully we can guide through that in a way that touches on things...
...that you think are really important.
While we're talking, I should add that I might make a few notes...
...and I hope that won't be distracting,...
...but it will help me and the rest of us who discuss candidates later on...
...since we interview so many people in any given day.